how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and if you are a fan and if you have
been waiting for the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series and the Wanda
vision series well this video has some
good news for you with everything from
pretty much all studios around the world
being put on hold production wise as far
as their shows and their movies go we've
had a lot of studios push back the
releases of their movies and shows some
have even gone as far as delaying them
over a year now of course it's all just
to keep safe the actors and the
production crew on these projects and of
course the people that go to the movie
theaters but as Marvel and movie fans
the weight has been killing us but
luckily for us we've had a few things
come to light that give us a little bit
of insight on the release dates for the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and the
Wanda vision series and it's good news
so let's break down these reports but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU also so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a black widow Funko pop all you
got to do subscribe like the video and
comment down below so first things first
let's talk about the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series it seems like this
could still be coming out in 2020
Anthony Mackie who of course plays
Falcon slash Sam in the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier as well as other Marvel
movies as well said on an interview on
The Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon
I'm happy to say we are not canceled we
are on hold so we're going back
hopefully some time soon to finish it up
and then very recently
Anthony Mackey's makeup artist posted
this to her Instagram story and it said
we're getting a black Captain America
this year so let's not cancel 2020 just
yet so this really kind of tells us two
things one is that if everything goes to
plan Marvel Studios is plan the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier is going to air
this year they are basically done with
all of the filming they have a little
bit left to do but Anthony Mackie seems
to think that they're going to go back
to shooting soon and Studios all over
the world right now are being given the
green light to open back up and it seems
like they're going to do that soon
especially since it's Anthony Mackey's
personal makeup artist she is in the
know about all of this but the second
thing that it tells us is that
may actually become Captain America in
the series obviously we know at the end
of Avengers endgame Sam kind of became
the new Captain America when Steve
Rogers gave him his shield however we
know that US agent John Walker is going
to be the first new Captain America in
the Falcon in the Winter Soldier series
and in the MCU now everybody has
expected that at some point in time Sam
will become Captain America and it seems
like we're going to see it in season one
this year but we have some more good
news about the Wanda vision series it
seems like we could get that showed this
year as well now recently this show was
pushed up to be released in December of
2020 when originally it was supposed to
come out in 2021 and right now it seems
like that may still happen if not it'll
be pretty close and now we have a little
bit of news to back that up in a recent
tweet from the official Twitter account
pop in a box to the home of the Funko
pop they tweeted right you asked for it
so we got it
Scarlet Witch confirmed P IA b.e X C
December / January and they say this was
confirmed yesterday so early days yet
but wanted to let you all know so we're
getting an official Scarlet Witch Funko
pop and normally these Funko pops
release right when the shows or the
movies release and they say that it's
coming in December or January which is
good evidence that the one division
series is still going to debut in
December or if not just a little after
in January and they're pretty much done
with filming as well a lot of editing
has been done for the show already so
just a little bit more filming and
they're practically done and that show
still has about six months until it's
December release date so it's looking
good for the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series and the one division
series to still release this year which
would be a great way to end 2020 census
Peschel e it didn't really start off
that well not to mention Black Widow
coming in November as well so let me
know which one are you more excited
about the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
or the one division series let me know
in the comments down below don't forget
to give the video a like and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
or Lading to the MCU for live updates
you can follow me on Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof